this is the delicious starter trust me
it's all in the preparation get
everything done first and then put it
together are you ready yeah ready
good here we go iceberg lettuce yes yeah
that needs okay the big shredding up the
big knife now to take the core off at
the bottom okay once the core is off yep
just press it down yeah lightly okay
we're going to cut it okay into nice
shreds right Chris this is the first
time you've ever cut lettuce in your
life I don't know what it is Chris it'll
make your hair grow okay right all right
okay good now we don't shred that too
fun otherwise it leads it sort of starts
to go a little bit limp right have a
card of time right
avocado yep nice yeah and we're gonna do
now just cut never cut in half yeah and
then roll the knife round and just give
that a little twist off in half now take
your big knife yep and get your stem
right now okay good
now get your knife and go across it what
we're doing basically is Criss crossing
across the avocado like so far yeah now
both ways now who are you cooking for
tonight my darling I'm cooking for my
sister Sophie my sister Natasha and my
brother Henry fantastic yes great big hi
mom it's a big family
yeah yeah right little bit lemon juice
yeah a squeeze hey yeah I'll take some
of mine thank you no bit lemon juice now
that goes around ever kado that stops it
from discoloring okay okay good now time
to make an amazing marrow sauce very
very simple and absolutely delicious
mayonnaise in a bowl yep
a little touch of Tabasco for heat yeah
just a couple drops oh that's what hello
yeah do you like it spicy yeah atashi
what's this hold a little pinch of
cayenne pepper right and then marrow
sauce would not be fantastic without
ketchup Oh
sorry Chris Mahal his favorite hot dear
oh dear favorite ingredient that please
like mine does not do that it sounds
slightly weird but it tastes absolutely
delicious that's nice did you just do a
bit rightly to touch Apprendi okay
okay give it a whisk okay and then from
there and it was squeezed fresh fresh
lemon juice